fox news contributor karl rove carl
let's just take
when you're in a white house and you
have a crisis and you wait on it
then you end up dealing with it for many
more news cycles if kamala harris had
gone to the border on the day
after the days after president biden
assigned her the task it might have been
one bad news cycle or so
instead they chose to have 90. oh yeah
absolutely
in fact let's go back to what she said
that day which really remarkable
she said we also this is the day she's
been appointed the borders are we also
understand that we will enforce the law
and that also because we can chew
gum and walk at the same time must
address the root causes
that cause people to make the trek well
i guess for 90 some odd days all she
could do is chew gum
because it's now over over three months
after she was appointed
that she's going to visit the border and
she's not as sen as representative
cuellar pointed out
she's not going to go to the part of the
border that's being adversely affected
governor abbott's right del rio is the
closest part of the border
to el paso that uh that that's being
affected adversely
and and that's like 250 miles away from
el paso and then you go further to
laredo into the rio grande valley you're
talking about 300 and some odd miles
to get to to brownsville and that's
where we're seeing la jolla
and uh and star county all of the aroma
all of these scenes that we've seen on
our television for week after week after
week
of people being smuggled across the
border in broad daylight by coyotes
who are thumbing their nose at u.s law
enforcement uh so this is a
very this is a self-made crisis quaar
was actually more direct than
what you're describing this is a
democratic congressman who's been
asking the white house and the vice
president to come down there for months
you know what he told us
he never got an answer and he
discriminated he described
el paso as politically safer for her to
visit absolutely look look the the
representative from
el paso was a democrat just like cuellar
but because the pres
it's entirely different in el paso in
fact it's really ironic
you go to the east of el paso to del rio
narrato
the lower rio grande valley and we have
an enormous problem
el paso is relatively stable compared
this year versus last year
you go to the west into new mexico and
arizona and it tends to get worse again
but the absolute worst part of the
of the border today and has been for
months is the lower rio grande valley
starting from brownsville and then going
up the river to laredo and all
all the way up to del rio and they're
not going there do you they're thumbing
their nose at the problem carl
just on timing we'd say like 90 days but
another there's another
point um president trump former
president trump is going to join
governor abbott
at the border next week do you think
that her timing of going
has anything to do with that oh
absolutely i think her
the administration's hand is finally
being forced i bet you've been there
plenty of meetings inside the white
house
where people are saying it this problem
is getting worse the longer you stay
away from the
from the border the worse it looks vice
president you need to get down there and
finally they agreed to go
she agreed to go but they're going at
the right to the wrong place there's
going to be another story about this
we're now going to start comparing the
numbers of border crossings and
apprehensions
in the el paso sector versus the other
three sectors to the east of
to the east of there del rio laredo and
the rio grande valley and we're going to
find out
that there's a lot bigger problem in the
places that she's not going to
than in the place she's going to thank
you carl karl rove
wow out of boston thank you